the death toll is rising in central
Mexico as rescuers search for more
earthquake survivors at least 266 people
were killed in Tuesday's 7.1 magnitude
quake more than 2,000 others are hurt
mexico's president believes there could
still be survivors in at least 10
collapsed building well before cuz his
outside Mexico City office building
where more than 40 people are still
missing
Manuel good morning good morning this
remains one of the most active
search-and-rescue sites throughout the
city there have been hundreds of workers
and volunteers in there scouring through
the debris is out here dozens of family
members can only watch and wait some
have posted flyers of the missing like
this one of a young woman named Catalina
they're desperate for answers the cries
of paulina gomez rang out as rescuers
tried to bring her to safety minutes
later she was pulled from the wreckage
[Music]
[Applause]
so far first responders in Mexico City
have pulled 60 survivors from the rubble
they're also using dogs to search for
missing people in the debris cuando
people Denis Ottawa Honda lucky how long
had he worked here what remains for
months only Guadalupe Salinas is looking
for her 26 year old son Gustavo one of
more than 40 people still listed as
missing from this collapse office
building she and her family have been
sleeping on the street as they wait for
any news you have to have faith not be
understand nothing I can't lose faith
she said until they tell us the search
is over I'll keep coming back here at
this destroyed elementary school
rescuers frantically dug for who they
thought was a little girl trapped
beneath the debris but the government
announced later that the person was
likely an adult and that no students
were believed to be there engineering
professor said haruko-san told us the
earthquake could have been much worse
but he pointed to updated building codes
and a seismic warning system created
after the 1985 quake that killed
thousands as reasons the city is still
standing I think one thing that is
important for our friends in the United
States to see is at Mexico City 24 hours
after the earthquake was functioning
this is a very resilient City
it's also a city that has tried to
prepare Tuesday's earthquake struck on
the exact anniversary of the 1985
earthquake and just after drills have
been conducted throughout the capital
Gale the nature's of mighty force thank
you very much Manuel Bojorquez reporting
from Mexico City